All right. Ron Diamont,
thank you so much
for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Gladly. I'm happy to be here.
All right I cannot wait to learn
over these next 20 minutes or so
about leadership and tech,
about what it's like being a very,
very, very early employee
like you were at Annapurna.
And you know, your incredible
experiences being a tech lead
at various very well-known
companies, I think most recently,
AWS, right?,
within Amazon.
So let's dive in.
Ron, tell me a little bit
about who you are.
Take me all the way back
to your time at the Technion,
you're doing your
bachelors and masters
and let's go from there.
All right. Cool.
So yeah, I did
I was in Academic Reserve.
I did my bachelor's
in electrical engineering
in the Technion.
After that, I went to the military,
worked as an engineer
for a couple of years.
During that time,
I did my master's as well.
I actually studied a lot
in my military service.
I enjoyed it quite a lot.
I know that many academic reserves
don't like that time so much,
but I enjoyed it.
After that I went,
after the military service,
I went to work
for an Israeli company
called Zoran,
a semiconductor company,
where I was doing
mostly math stuff.
So kind of an intersection
of mathematics and engineering.
So, error correction codes,
security applications,
and all things that are
kind of math related.
After a while,
Zoran got acquired by CSR,
a British company.
And with that, I found myself
moving to a startup that was,
in the very early days
if I recall correctly
I was employee number seven there.
Wow.
Startup was
it's called Annapurna Labs.
After about four years,
Annapurna got acquired by AWS,
which was interesting
especially with my previous
acquisition experience,
which wasn't that positive.
But that acquisition with AWS
was actually quite amazing.
AWS is a great technology
playground and we can talk
about that a little bit.
And since then I'm in AWS.
I actually got the chance
to initiate a product for AWS,
machinery related,
and maybe we can talk
about it later as well.
Incredible.
Did they disclose the deal
of the acquisition for Annapurna?
There is enough
information online, yeah.
Enough information online.
So I'm gonna have
to attach it afterwards
at the top
But you know, I have to ask
what is it like being
a very early employee
at a place like Annapurna?
I mean that's a very different
experience from being
a founder of the company.
You've essentially been
in the same room as them,
practically from the very very
very first days, yet you had
very different experiences.
So talk to me a little bit about
what's it like being
a very early employee.
First of all, I
highly, highly recommended it
especially if you're joining
a founding team that is
experienced and know
what they're doing.
It's a great experience.
So, I would say
it's scary at the beginning.
Yeah.
It's scary because
you take your,
you typically reduce
your salary a little bit.
You join a team that you don't know
how things will play out with.
You don't have a defined role.
You do whatever is needed.
Right.
But it's a blast.
I mean you, instead of
being very focused in one
of the big companies like,
I won't mention other
companies' names actually,
but instead of being
very focused on your day job,
you get to do whatever task
is needed at the time.
And if you are willing to go out
of your comfort zone,
you go out of your comfort zone
all the time.
So, I was hired to do one thing.
I think I did everything else
in the company other than
the thing I was hired to do.
I learned a lot during these years.
I learned a lot
from the founders who were,
these guys were experienced.
They were VPs in Marvell
prior to founding Annapurna Labs.
All in all, I think
it was a blast.
And one thing that
I keep telling other folks
is that what's different
between a startup and a big company
is that when you're in a startup,
everyone wants for everyone else
to succeed because you succeed
and fail together.
And in a big company,
that's not exactly the vibe
that you're getting
and the entire day-to-day
becomes completely different
once you work as a team
and try to succeed together.
Incredible.
So how long did you spend
at Annapurna
as employee number seven?
So Annapurna grew very quickly.
I spent four years in Annapurna
from joining until we got acquired.
But Annapurna grew
from seven to about 25
in a matter of six months.
Wow!
And from there,
in the next two to three years,
we grew to 120.
And today, we're way more than that
but I cannot disclose the number
because it's internal data.
Wow. Incredible.
Okay. And so at the end,
you're saying on one hand,
you joined an early-stage startup.
It's a lot of fun.
You're a part of the team.
It's not really defined.
It's not structured, so you get,
it's like a big playground.
And you get to be a part of,
hopefully, a very nice
success story like
the acquisition to AWS.
But the alternative,
the drawback is that
it's more risky,
you usually take a pay cut
for that potential, you know,
milestone later on, right?
Absolutely.
But what I would recommend
for junior engineers is to
not think about the short-term
salary or compensation.
Think about the long-term
just and the amount that you will
learn in a small company
as in a startup
is way higher than what you will
learn in a big company.
Right, definitely.
But then I mean
you can't just go and
it almost seems irresponsible
to just go and join
any early-stage startup
because it seems exciting.
I mean at the end you do
want some stability
and a lot of early-stage
startups today,
I mean they don't automatically
offer you compensation.
So what are your tips on sort of,
you know, balancing the two ideas
and what type of due diligence
can you do on an early-stage
company before joining?
So my
I don't know if I have a very
well-thought set of tips
but I can tell about my story.
I want to know your experience.
Yeah. So, what I did is
I started
When Zoran got acquired,
I figured that this is not going
in the right direction.
And that's one recommendation
that I can give.
Don't look only at your day-to-day.
Think about where the company
is going long-term.
Right.
Once I saw that this is not
going in the right direction,
I started looking.
And I was pretty young.
I wanted to experience a startup.
So, one of the things
that I started doing
is to look at startups
that are out there today.
And I was just looking
at the newspaper,
asking folks around.
When I, all of a sudden,
heard about Annapurna.
What excited me there is,
first of all, they were
in very early days.
I think they were in one month
after being founded.
Wow
The second thing that
I noted immediately
is that the founders
were folks with a significant
experience and
very well-established record.
Right.
That was a good sign for me.
And the third thing that
I noticed is that the
Bond?
Sorry, the chairman of the board,
the person that gave them
the seed money
was a well-known person
in the semiconductor industry.
Okay.
Avigdor Willenz.
He has a record of
founding companies
that eventually become successful.
Wonderful.
These were good signs for me.
I also went
and talked with my dad.
My dad works in the field
and he knew
all these folks and said,
"Thumbs up from me.
I know these guys.
These guys know
what they're doing.
Go for it" and I went.
I love it. I love it.
Okay. At the end,
that's the most important
advice: talk to dad.
They have the best
advice in the end
from experience.
But Ron, then you
transitioned to AWS.
So now, you're a part of a much
larger organization
and it's no longer,
you know, you're no longer
just employee number seven
but you, and while you may be
leading your
own product within AWS,
I mean you're still part
of a new culture.
You have to adapt
and assimilate into a whole new,
you know, type of company.
How is that progression like
and what are some of the
challenges that go with it?
So first of all,
immediately after acquisition,
you have a big shock
because all of a sudden,
there's all this terminology
and terminology and culture
that you are not familiar with.
Right.
And you're starting
to study quite a lot.
And basically coming up
to speed very quickly.
It's very natural,
in my experience,
at least, to feel
like the dumbest person
in the room immediately
after acquisition,
because everyone has
the experience of
the previous years
and you're coming in
completely fresh.
- Right.
What I would
recommend is, first of all,
learn as quickly
and as much as you can.
But on the other hand,
don't take things without
applying some judgment.
So, there were things
that I liked about the AWS culture.
There were things that I didn't
like about AWS culture.
And I think it was
the correct thing for me,
at least, to integrate
with the stuff that
I could connect with
and not blindly go
with everything that I saw,
and be patient.
At the end of the day you need to know
the people, you need to know
the technology,
you need to know the history,
and then you can function.
Totally. Okay.
So let's move on to this idea
of team execution,
lean execution,
and what makes
or breaks a good team,
not just about whether people
like each other or whether
they have a good time
in the office but also about
actually executing products,
because you've seen
the good and the bad.
So talk to me a little bit
about what are some
of the key takeaways
of a good engineering team.
So I think a lot of it
is about ownership.
So what I see in different teams
is when people own things
from beginning to end,
things tend to converge
much more smoothly.
So what I see in many things
that are not delivering
very quickly is that everyone
has their role and their doing
what they're asked to do,
and that's it.
They stop with,
they stop their
responsibility there.
They don't continue to check
with the next person in line,
whether they got everything
that they needed,
whether it's working
for them and so on.
One thing that I like to do is,
first of all,
make sure that people
that are working on a product,
own this product from A to Z,
even things that
they don't do themselves.
And it takes some iterating
with people to get
into that mentality,
but when people do it,
first of all, it's way more fun
because you don't just execute
on tasks.
You basically own
the entire product.
You feel like the product is yours.
That's a big advantage.
The other thing
that you see
is that there are way
less miscommunications
because when people are
people are not just building
a product to a certain
specification, but rather
actually speaking
with their customer,
whether it's local in the team
or another team,
and understanding their needs,
understanding whether the product
that they receive
actually meets their goals
and so on.
And that makes a huge difference.
I would say
that's my number one.
My number two,
and that's probably debatable,
but I don't believe
in overly documenting things.
I think projects move fast
if you don't know everything
in the beginning of the project.
If you try to document
every decision that
you're going to make,
and then you try to execute
that to that specification,
by the time you start executing,
the entire specification
became irrelevant because
the industry is moving forward.
So that's about
the lean part of it, right?
Exactly.
So I strongly believe
in doing 50 percent
of the specification work,
working based on
gut feeling, understanding
of the overall direction,
but starting to execute
while keeping on iterating
and closing the rest of the -
But is that feasible
within a large organization
like AWS when you,
inevitably, you have these
best practices and conventions
in place because you have to align,
you know, thousands of engineers?
It's feasible but you need
to be clever about it.
So I think you don't always say,
"Hey, listen, I have fifty percent
of the product specified.
Go execute."
That doesn't work.
But you say,
"Okay, I have a specification.
Here's the specification."
And we make sure
that the team starts to execute
with the portion
of the specification
that you actually
have high confidence in.
And you also do communicate
that there are some unknowns
that you're still working on,
but as long as you close
the unknowns before they get
to executing it,
I think that's it's doable.
Definitely.
So how many of these
How many different teams
and products would you say
that you've worked
on over the years?
That's a good question.
I would say roughly six
or seven chips that I worked on.
Wow
And they all are very similar
and very different from each other.
So it's an interesting
thing to ponder on.
I'm sure.
And then
So what's the role of the leader
of an organization,
a small organization,
that needs to execute
on a product?
So fine, so you have,
you know, the engineers are,
you know, they're working,
they're lean, they're documenting
not documenting
but what's the role
of the team lead
or the technical leader
of such a product?
So I think,
first of all,
the technical leader
or the team leader
if everyone sees them as a leader,
they already made a mistake.
They need to drive the culture
where decisions are made
in a distributed manner.
Okay
If every single decision
gets escalated up,
you already
the team doesn't scale.
You already made a mistake.
The second thing in my mind
is to drive the culture
of the team.
First of all, collaboration
Second, being very focused
on execution.
So, one thing that happens
in many engineering
organization is endless debates
on the best way to do things.
I think you need to drive
a culture in the team
where you spend your time
on what actually matters.
And if there are a couple
of decisions that
will move the needle
by one percent,
just make a decision,
move on even if
it's the wrong decision.
No big deal.
The third thing,
I would say,
is constant prioritization
and communication across the team.
So a project is complex,
you don't know exactly
what you're getting into
at the beginning of the project.
So there's no way
you can prioritize
all the tasks
for the next year and a half.
And I'm talking chip products
that take a year
and a half to execute.
You cannot prioritize
the entire thing at day one.
So you need to constantly go in
and prioritize, especially because
as the chip,
as the project nears an end,
you're going to give up
on some features.
So it's better that these will be
the less important features.
And it's endless, right?
Communication across the team,
I think, is also key
Making sure that people
actually understand
so that they make
the right decision
in their everyday
in their day-to-day.
So I spend, I guess,
30 percent of my time
just explaining things
to every single engineer
that is willing to listen
because I think, eventually,
it's worth it.
People make better
decisions based on that.
Do you
So this idea of foregoing
some features and leaving and
you know, deferring
the least important ones
to the end
this prioritization
I mean, at the end, that's one
of the hardest things,
I think, to do especially
as a team leader, right?
You have the product,
you have the product specifications,
but you have all these conflicting
notions of what's important,
what's critical,
what's not critical.
And a lot of that is also,
you know, not just about
the product and requirement
but it's about the actual
implementation of the product
and whether you want to go
the extra mile
implement it better,
or do you want to release it,
you know, a few sprints
ahead of time?
Yeah. So I think
the more, I feel with time that
the more educated I am,
and the more time
I spend into looking
into every point of the project,
the easier it is for
me to prioritize.
So at the beginning,
I would always almost feel
like I'm improvising
and it's really tough
to make the decision.
But if I look in retrospective
it's because I wasn't
educated enough.
I didn't see
all the different disciplines
and how things come together.
As time passes
and I gain more experience,
I can see that
the more that you know,
the easier it is to do it,
and the more comfortable
you feel not taking
every decision yourself
but rather consulting
with the entire team
to make the decision.
Definitely. Okay.
Ron, I have to know,
what excites you most?
So you've done all sorts of things.
You've worked
at a variety of places
but what really
gets you excited about
being an engineer
and leading teams?
It's interesting.
I think the challenge
the challenge is definitely
a big one for me just starting
a new technology,
especially new technologies
which I know nothing about,
just getting into this
technology space,
learning it, and then may
becoming an expert,
and eventually executing
and building something
that customers like and use.
Definitely the human part of it,
so interacting with smart people,
finding your way
to deliver together as a team,
going through some hardships
during the project
and finding clever ways around it,
whether it's technical
or human related.
So people get frustrated,
people get tired
during a long execution,
and we find
clever ways together.
And one thing that I enjoy the most
is being super open
with the team about it
and just telling them
my considerations
and trying to make
the decision together.
For me, if we get to a point
in the project where we feel
that we reached a problem
and we don't know what to do,
and if I can come into
a conversation
and just ask questions
and the team decides
on the best path forward,
that's a lot of fun.
Fascinating.
Okay. Ron, one or two pieces
of advice you would give
to any engineer that is
starting their journey,
whether it's an early-stage startup
or a late-stage startup,
but let's say somebody
fresh out of college.
You know, they just got
their bachelor's or master's
in computer science,
they're joining a new company.
What should they keep in mind
most importantly?
I think one, I would say,
is focus on building
your core capabilities.
So too many people
I see are trying to
kind of race through
the career ladder,
become a manager,
and then get
this certain level
or something like that.
I don't think this is the most
important thing in the long term.
In the long term, actually,
if you build capabilities,
you build knowledge
across disciplines,
I think that's worth much more
and you start to accelerate
very quickly later on.
That's one. A second one is
the world became multidisciplinary.
You don't
Becoming an expert
in one narrow topic
is not enough anymore.
So try to experience,
to gain experience with
a couple of different disciplines,
whether it's software or hardware.
It could be even broader than that.
A third one is,
and it's related,
but think long term.
Don't think short term.
And a fourth one
is be nice to people.
Make people like you.
Eventually it will pay up.
The most important probably.
Yeah.
And going off of that,
Ron, 20 minutes are up
but I need to know three words
that best describe you.
All right. Let's see if I can
get this one quickly.
The most important question.
The hardest one.
So I think
First of all, I'm adaptable.
If things are thrown my way,
I'll find a way around them,
whether personally
or as a team, when we build things.
Second one, I would say,
nice and kind to people.
We work together.
I'm not trying
to compete with them.
I don't hear that often.
It's so important though.
I mean it's such a basic thing.
No matter what you do in life,
no matter the level you are
and the experience you've had,
just being kind and being nice,
being humane
I totally agree with that.
I couldn't agree more.
And third one,
I don't know, I find,
it's kind of like adaptable,
but I find a path forward always.
I'm very optimistic.
I know that there will
be a way to succeed.
I love it.
Sounds like the really important
traits of an engineer.
Ron, thank you very much.
Thank you for everything,
for all the inspiration,
for all the knowledge.
I think this is
hugely relevant to my path,
hugely relevant to a lot
of the people
that are following this show.
And they're also young engineers
on their path and on their journey.
So thank you for your time.
Thank you for having me.
Bye-bye.
Bye.